dejamos los deportes de invierno y
hablamos ahora de deportes de verano
porque yulimar rojas la reina del salto
triple regreso a las competencias este
sábado pero no lo hizo participando en
su habitual modalidad sino en el salto
largo donde consiguió un segundo lugar
con un salto de
6.55 metros si bien el mar cubrió la
misma distancia que la ganadora a la
competencia la cantidad de fans fueron
en contra de la venezolana pero qué
condiciones tiene tul y mar para ser
competitiva en cuanto al salto largo
esta temporada esta temporada es muy
particular para yulimar porque es la
primera vez en la historia que ella va a
participar en salto largo como evento
fundamental recordemos que ya después de
su triunfo en el salto triple de los
juegos de tokio dijo que ella ahora
pretendía ganar las medallas de oro
tanto en triple como en largo en el
campeonato del mundo entonces es primera
vez que sé que ya no emplea el largo
como parte de su preparación para el
triple sino que tiene objetivos
específicos también en el largo por eso
tal vez comienza la temporada diferente
a como normalmente
siempre empieza sorprendiendo con unas
marcas
espectaculares en esta oportunidad no
estuvo muy lejos de su récord personal
bajo techo que es de 8 de 659 pero sí de
sus récords absolutos que ya tiene 1 688
al aire libre
puede que obedezca a esta circunstancia
de estarse preparando para los dos altos
a la vez y siempre cabe preguntarse si
ese plan se va a mantener hasta último
momento